well the Rockets they got to go into the
second half of the season last year they
took off last year deep three floods Oh
Paul straight away and he did not
succeed beyond the r-class 933 and 12
let Russell shoot that one out there
beautiful there's the pass salons oh boy
Lonzo you can knock that three-point
shot down but that's what he was drafted
to be by capela
then three-point shot by house and that
looked like a turn over to John charge
saves it and gets the roll Josh hard his
fearless yeah he attacked Jenner's
wanted to go to Jaleel in for the firs
time couldn't take Brandon Ingram on the
hammer that's six unanswered now make it
seven unanswered by the PAL still a lead
for the Houston Rockets paint room
coming off the pitch you got wet in
patience parsing pasted my friend in
England he had Westbrook on his back to
be excellent patience by Brendan England
a little more than three and a play hard
got Gordon out of position Lonzo ball
Kenshin shoes and he gets the triple
delegates on top 5.50 49 lonzo's second
three-pointer purse to the Chicago Bulls
get drafted
now lines up all on the take away Josh
Hart spacing triples got it over the
night against Houston Valley rolling
instead picking a pop yes beautiful Pels
by two it is even 258 point to the paint
once again that's 32 to 20 team triple
for Lonzo ball not too deep I guess 6158
is now 2 for 12 with that make from
beyond the arc
only 5 of 16 overall and that's after 4
shooting game it'll be Derrick Favors
and good patience again where the
England is playing an excellent floor
game the whale that's a tough call
now favors turns around heart gets there
and he'll finish use favours effectively
did that is big in this game
huge making up some of the discrepancy
on the made free throws you said it
dumped my lawn so bold and the Pels up
by three Brandon Ingram size advantage
raised up you got a five-point lead for
the Pels up against Westbrook turn and
fire over here comes the double look how
many guys got punted yard raised logs
capitalizes Brandon Ingram he didn't
panic didn't right and he's got the
floater doesn't get it doesn't get the
finger roll he's behind the play man
advantage on the run Brandon Inge rub
book fee violence they blended that hard
just reached on Ingram
now he's gonna Josh Hart green the
corner big triple
124 121 you gotta bow
half the foul heart falls down goes the
other
hurry and one-point game with 11.4 to
play - in case you don't have to file
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content